皆さんはじめまして
僕は今この大学に通っております今年4回
生の年になります中谷智也と申します
今回スピーカーの中で
唯一こう学生枠というところで
学生目線でかつ学生に向けた内容です
メッセージをお届けしたいと思いますので
よろしくお願いいたします
はいそれではまずテーマからもう出てるん
ですけども
学生期間における挑戦の必要性とは
調整っていうテーマでお話ししていこうか
なと思うんですけれどもまあそもそもまあ
挑戦ってまあどういったものなのか
でまぁ定義みたいなところなんですけど
どういったものがありますかねまあ
せっかくなので
ぜひなんかお客様に
したいんですけどなんか
誰かご協力いただける方とかって
いらっしゃいますか
あありがとうございますじゃあそこのお
名前伺っていいですよ荒木と申します
荒木さんありがとうございますなんか
アーティストさんにとって今までこう人生
でこれ挑戦してきたなーみたいななんか
思ったりしますかそうですねまず
受験とかもそうですしやっぱり人前で発表
するとかそういうのも挑戦なのかなと思い
ます
ですかありがとうございますなんか学生だ
からこそのまあ受験とかでものすごく
大きな挑戦なのかなと思いますありがとう
ございますありがとうございますはい
他にもまあ大学生であれば留学だったりと
かまあ人によってはこう起業したりとか
まあサークル立ち上げみたいなところも
いろんな挑戦があると思うんですけれども
それが全部ひっくるめて
挑戦ってどうなのどんなものなのかなって
思った時に
僕こういうものかなんて思ってます
未知の世界の扉を叩き自身をアップデート
すること
だと思ってますまあちょっとこされた言い
方にはなってるんですけどもまあ要は今
までやったことがないことをまあやって
みるでその
って
今までのこう
自分自身の成長するまあ機会であり
手段それが僕はこう挑戦かなっていうふう
に思ってます
では
実際そんな挑戦なんですけれども
なんで学生にとって挑戦が必要なのかって
いう話なんですが
実際僕もいろんな校長選をしてきてまあ
絶対こう知識であったりとかなんかそう
いったこうメリットデメリットみたいな
ところも踏まえた上でこういった要素が
あるよっていうのもお伝えしたいんです
けれどもまず1点目にまあ新たな出会いと
いうところ
あと2点目にハードルが低いそして最後に
選択肢が増えるっていうまあ要素で
挑戦が
学生にとって必要じゃないかなと
お伝えします
まず
新たな出会いっていうので
先ほどの通り
挑戦っていうのは今までやったことがない
ことをやってみるって言うので
新たなこう人との出会いだったりとかあと
自分自身の新たな一面の出会いみたいな
ところもものすごく重要なのかなって
要は今までやったことがないことで
自分自身あこういうところで楽しいと思う
んだとかこういうことを好きなんだなとか
まあ
調整によったらこう強みだったりとかまあ
弱みま仕事の適性みたいなところもま自分
自身にこう見えてくるのかなと
で僕自身も4回戦なんでちょっと前まで
就活しててまあそういうこう自分の
自己分析みたいなところってまあすごく
重要でまあいろいろこう自分自身苦戦した
ところもあったんですけどまあいろいろ
やってきた中でまあいろいろそういう自分
のやりたい方向性とかま強みだったりとか
まあこういうところで楽しいんだなって
思うところが
すごい明確に見えたのでまぁだからこそ
こう出会いってところは
挑戦に必要性もまあはずですで2つ目
ハードルが低いというまあ4人で字の
ごとく思うんですが
学生と社会人だと
全然挑戦のハードルが違うと思ってて
それこそ社会人の方だと
仕事があったりとか
家族がいたりとかいろんなしがらみがある
中でまあ
僕も学生でいろいろイメージつくんです
けど
学生ってものすごく時間あり余ってると
いうか人によってはすごい暇な時間も多く
ある期間だと思っています
まあそういった中で
挑戦のハードルっていうのが全然違う今だ
からこそやるべきだと思いますし
実際やってみると社会人の方と
かもまあ今ハードルが低い今だからこそ
やるべきなのかなっていうのが2つ目
そして3つ目
選択肢が増えるというところでちょっと
これ僕のなんか経験も踏まえてお伝えし
たいんですけど
実際僕あの大学に入る前
と入った後も
実際こう
将来どういう仕事をしたいとかどういう
人生歩んでいきたいとか
全然もう明確じゃなくて見えてなかったん
ですそういった学生もすごく多くいると
思います
で
入ってみたらそういうのって見えてくるの
かなと思ってたんですけどまあそんなもの
あのまあ降ってくるもんでもなくてま全然
まああのま大学の1年間に2年間とか見え
てなかったんですけど
でそんな中であの挑戦っていうのをまず
こう1つテーマとして大学生活置いて
いろんなちょっとこういろんなことをやっ
てみようって思ってまあその過程で
いろんな人と出会っていろんなことを知っ
てでいろんなことをやってみてっていうの
でやっていくうちに
結果的になんかこう自分のこうどういう
キャリアを歩んでいきたいとかどういう
人生を歩んでいきたいみたいなところが今
すごく明確に持てていてこれってなんか
学生っていう目線で言うとものすごく素敵
なことかなーっていうふうに思ってますな
のでそういったこう選択肢増やして
自分のこう納得感の持てるを人生法という
かなんかそういうライフプランみたいな
建てるためにはまあいろいろ選択肢増やし
ていくっていうのは
必要なのかなっていうのが3点目です
今まとめると
新たなこう挑戦みたいなところをしていく
ことで
新たな自分との出会いだったりとかあとは
将来の
選択肢
みたいなところを増やせるだからこそ学生
の今だからこそ
挑戦ってのやった方がいいんじゃないかな
と
まあいろんな経験を経て思い
ますで
僕がやってきた挑戦
ちょろっとご紹介したいんですけれども
結構いろいろやってきました一部なんです
けれどもまあプログラミングとか
クラウドファンディングとかデジタル
マーケティングみたいなまあ今風のもの
だったりとかあとこうmlmっていうま
いわゆるマルチみたいなところとかあと
彫金ターンっていうのは
実際こう学生ながら社会人と同じような
業務を積んでしっかりとこうあのお給料も
いただけるみたいな
色々経験できるアルバイトバージョン
みたいなものです
そういった形で言えばいろいろこう手出し
てみてやってみたんですけどまあ結果的に
ほとんどうまくいかなかったんです
プログラミングは3ヶ月ぐらいでまず説明
して
クラウドファンディングデジタル
マーケティングは
実際行動に移すまでもいけなくてまあ
いろいろこう調べているうちにあこれ
ちょっと合わないなって思ってやめちゃっ
たりとかまあ
NMこれマルチに関してはもうあまりこう
いいイメージはないと思うんですけどま
とりあえずこうやってみようって思うので
あの半月ほどやって
やめちゃったんですけど
実際その半月で10年代にこう親友失い
かけたりとかいろんなこう失敗してきた中
でまあ唯一こう彫金探偵のが
自分自身いろんな経験をして今実際
続けてい
るっていうのもあるんですけどまあ唯一
こうまあよかったかなっていう
これぐらいこういろいろやってきてまあ
こう
ネットとかでもよく見ると思うんですけど
ま調整っていうのはやっぱりほとんどが
やっぱうまい
思い通りにならないのかなっていうふうに
思っててはいこれはもう僕自身の経験も
いろんなやってきた人の意見でもそうなん
ですけど
ほとんどうまいこといかないです
ただ
挑戦してもしくは失敗してしまったとして
も
次にこう生かしていくでその失敗をデータ
に変えていったら
すごくこう前に進んでいくんじゃないか
なっていうふうに思っててこれはちょっと
捉え方のところにもなるんですけどもまあ
失敗して下の部分じゃなくてま上を向いて
まあどんどんこう成功に近づくための糧に
していった方がいいよっていうま捉え方な
んですけど
これちょっと僕
好きな言葉があって
トーマスエジソンていう
皆さんご存知の電球の人なんですけどはい
この
先生がこんな言葉を残しました
私は人生で一度も
失敗したことがない
私は
電球が光らない発見を2万回しただけだ
初めて聞いた時いや屁理屈じゃんもう
広い木やみたいなところ思ったんですけど
よくよく色々考えてみるとなんかそこの
こうメッセージ性みたいなところが
結構僕の思ってるとこと一緒かなと思って
てまあ要は失敗してもまあ下を向かずに
上を向いていけと
失敗は
成功するために必要不可欠なものなんだ
よっていうメッセージを
届けたかったのかなというふうに思って
ますまあそういったメッセージに受け取っ
てまあいろんなこう挑戦を経てやってき
てるんですけれども
実際今もめっちゃくちゃ大きな挑戦してて
そこも
ちょっと今は僕
先ほどもインターンずっと今も言って
るって言ったんですけど
新規事業の立ち上げの
挑戦をしててまあどういったことをやっ
てるのかというと
彫金タンま僕みたいに
インターンを経験している学生つ目の
コミュニティみたいなの
運営してます
でコミュニティていうとなんて言うんです
かね学生目線で言うとちょっとマルチ
みたいなイメージがあったりとかするか
なって思うんですけどなんかここに持って
あの
すごくあの明確なビジョンを持ってやって
いてどういったものなのかで言うと
僕はこのコミュニティ立ち上げた経緯
みたいなところで言うと
常勤単経験者だけの
採用市場
新しい新卒の採用市場みたいな作りたいな
と思ってて
で行方不その先に
親切で
ジョブ型雇用を実現したいなっていうふう
に思って
ますまああまり聞き慣れない言葉かと思う
んですけど
ちなみに皆さんジョブ型雇用とかって聞い
たことある人っていますか
ありがとうございます
なんか
ジョブ型雇用っていわゆるこう海外が採用
手法みたいな形で
入社前からどういった職種だったりとか
事業部だったりとかどういった内容どう
いった人と働きますみたいなところを
明確に持った上で
仕事を
引き受けるみたいな
形の雇用形態なんですけどこういったら
新卒で実現したいなっていうふうに思って
てそれなんでなのかなっていうところなん
ですけど
実際僕自身も
将来をやりたいこととかこういう人生歩ん
でいいっていきたいこういうキャリア
プランで
歩んでいきたいみたいなところを明確に
持ってる中で
僕自身こう就活してた時に今のこう新卒
市場ってなんかこうファーストキャリア
どこの事業部とか入るかわからないみたい
な入社してみないかわからないみたいな
ところがすごいリスクに感じてがあってだ
からこそ
新卒でそういうジョブ型みたいなところを
実現したいでそのために
彫金単線いっぱい集めてそういう採用紙を
作ったらできるんじゃないかみたいな
ところから
授業まあコミュニティを立ち上げてます
まあこういった大きな挑戦してると
周りの大人の方々とか
同年代の学生の人たちから
めっちゃ頑張ってるじゃん
すごいねみたいなところをよく言われて
言われてで
すごいいい経験できてるねとも
言われるんですけどまあ実際僕もそう思っ
てて
すごく今いい経験できてるなと思ってて
学生ながらこう新規事業の立ち上げとかっ
てあまりこうできる経験じゃない
でそういうこう嬉しい意見ももらったりと
かしてすごいモチベーションにつながっ
たりはしてるんですけど
実際でもキラキラしたものだけじゃなくて
めちゃくちゃ辛いことも多くてこれ
自体あの先ほどの通り今までこう全くこう
いうコミュニティの運営とか
事業の立ち上げみたいなところって
僕自身やったことがなかったので
色々こう試行錯誤してやったりするんです
けどまぁ
ほとんどやっぱりうまいこといかなくて
でそこでこう大きなこう挑戦だったりとか
小さい挑戦ちっちゃないろんなこう思考
錯誤してでその数だけ失敗して挫折して
みたいな
ところですごいこうまあ
端的にとって辛いというか
苦しい時
期もしてます
でそれだけじゃなくて
僕自身こう僕のインターンの会社って完全
成果報酬っていう
売上立てた分のパーセンテージだけ売上
あのお給料をもらえるみたいな
形で
実際僕まあ1年弱ぐらいこの授業
設計なんかも含めてやってるんですけど
あの
未だにお給料0円でやってて数百時間
ぐらいやって
で他のインターン生は他の事業部で
ちゃんと成果出してお給料もうガンガン
貰っていってるみたいなところでなんか
そこのボレット感だったりとかまあ悔しさ
みたいなところもすごく感じててだから
こそめちゃくちゃ辛いところがあるんです
けどただ
今めちゃくちゃ充実してて今
生活が
でめちゃくちゃワクワクしながらあのこの
授業を運営してるんですけどまあなんでな
のかなって思った時に
やっぱりこのコミュニティというか事業
自体こういう新卒でジョブ型声を実現し
たいとかはこういう採用市場を作りたい
みたいなところを
明確に持ってて
僕自身それを人生かけてまで挑戦したいな
と思えるぐらい前のめりに頑張りたいと
思って
なんかそういうこう人生かけてまで
挑戦したいと思えるものってまあ
なんていうんですかね
メリットというか目に見えるメリットが
なくても頑張れるというか
で
実際それをまあ将来仕事としてお給料を
もらえる
形の
再現性もちゃんと見えてるからこそ今
頑張れてるか
なでこれまあ色々話しましたが何を伝え
たかったのかというと
皆さんにも人生かけてまで
挑戦したいと思えるようなものを見つけて
ほしいなと
で
先ほどの通り
こう人生限り挑戦したいみたいな前のめり
になったらやる気とかなんか
モチベーション高く保てるよってところも
あるんですけれども
実際ここで
この前ググったんですけど
社会人の方ってどれぐらい仕事してるのか
なって見た時になんか人生のま3割ぐらい
仕事をしている時間みたいなデータがあっ
てで
社会人の人の
結構あの見える部分なんですけどあの
仕事をお金を稼ぐ目的としてしか見てない
みたいな人も
数多くいると思っててなんかその3割を
犠牲にして残りの7割充実させるために
頑張るみたいなのでなんかもったいないな
というか
だからこそこういう仕事みたいなところも
すごくこう人生の充実というかワクワクし
ながら
仕事する人が増えたらいいしなんかそう
思えるような
仕事を見つけるためには自分自身のこう
挑戦色々
積み重ねてそういうものを見つけていくと
いうのが大切かなとでそれを
学生期間だからこそやるべきなんじゃない
かなと
思いますただそういう挑戦っていきなり
見えるものではなくてなんでいきなり
大きな挑戦ってのは全く必要ないかなと
思います
ちっちゃなちっちゃな挑戦の積み重ね連続
で
成功体験どんどん積んでいって
そうして挑戦をちょっとずつちょっとずつ
まあ大きくしていくでその先に
人生の
挑戦みたいなのまあ見つけてほしいと思い
ますでもっと言うとそういう挑戦を
仕事にできるぐらいの
再生を持って
まあモテるようなものを見つけてほしいな
というふうに
なんで
結構そういう挑戦ってあの
すごくこう一歩踏み出すようなこう挑戦
っていうの学生にとってこう僕もそうだっ
たんですけど1歩ねってすごいハードルが
高かったりするんですけど
まあそういう時は
僕でもいいですし
周りの大人たちでもいいんですし
周りのこう挑戦している学生とかでもいい
ので
助けを求めると何かしら絶対
助けてくれますし何かしらこう
力になってくれるのでどんどん
自分自身の挑戦っていうのをなんかこう
自分自身下げてどんどん挑戦していって
ほしいなっていうふうにまあ今回思って
ます
なので
いろいろお話しさせていただきましたが
まあ今回何を伝えたかったのかというと
挑戦っていうのをまあ皆さん知ってほしい
というところと
みんなこう
みんなでそういう挑戦を盛り上げるような
環境というか社会を実現したいなという
ふうに思うので
ぜひ何かあれば
僕でもいいですし周りの隣たち助けを求め
て一人でも何か今回のお話で
挑戦するきっかけ
づくりができたらいいなというふうに思い
ます
本日ありがとうございました
[拍手]